postman nicola de mille has almost
finished his rounds he often stops for a
chat to Yosh is a small close-knit
community families here stick together
on the other side of the river - there
are large families who all live in the
same neighborhood geology is located in
southern Belgium on the river Meuse this
part of Wallonia boasts in a Dilla
landscape with gently rolling hills and
in the heart of it lies the tianj
nuclear reactor surrounded by family
homes but that doesn't bother people
here though Adobe has just bought and
renovated this bar locals gather here at
lunch or after work owning her own pub
is Dooley's dream she moved here
specially from namu the Wallow nyan
capital
most of her customers work just across
the way at the power station it's great
for me it's a huge advantage I didn't
have to try and drum up business the
customers were already here and being
right across from the reactor doesn't
worry me joy no Pete Lee is an
electrician who's worked at the tianj
reactor for over two decades he says
they do enough to ensure people's safety
we always have to wear a protective suit
helmet goggles and gloves and we always
work in pairs belgium is home to two
nuclear power plants they produce ample
electricity for the relatively small
country belgium has relied on atomic
energy for decades its citizens trust
the technology is a country at the
crossroads of three great cultures the
germanic Latin and anglo-saxon cultures
they've always been various influences
and it's not a very old country so they
have always been compromises this is
made us pragmatic and rational we have
to make deals and cooperate with others
if we don't it's over for us the company
that runs the nuclear facilities is
paying the Belgian state hundreds of
millions of euros to extend the lifespan
of the plants if Belgium had opted to
close one down the state would be the
one shelling out millions there's a
signed document which they first tried
to keep secret which states that the
Belgian state has to pay this money
within 30 days on the price of
electricity it amounts to around 200
million euros
Belgium's Agency for nuclear control
first needs to certify the reactor
safety but the Green Party says there's
a questionable entanglement between
politicians and the nuclear lobby you
need to realise that the director of the
agency worked for the French nuclear
power company for decades
after a shutdown millions of euros
changed hands just so TR could start
operating again neighboring countries
Germany and the Netherlands criticized
the decision saying that Tiana's aging
reactors are unsafe they're now over 30
years old
and cracks have appeared but Nakula de
Mille says folks here aren't concerned I
can only say that new families keep
moving here the ones here are new and
the ones over there too living in the
shadow of a nuclear reactor isn't most
people's dream but in theology they view
things pragmatically housing prices are
cheap here a big advantage for business
minded Belgians